c'est la fin d'une histoire qui durait
depuis 1975 le 31 mai prochain
l'association plaisir jeunesse aura mis
la clé sous la porte
la clôture des conventions qui les lient
au département et à la municipalité
mettra un terme à l'action de ce club de
prévention spécialisée
normalement c'est des gens donc de dix à
vingt cinq ans la relation de confiance
c'est la base de notre travail avec ces
jeunes
et du coup a donc aucun prison ils
rencontrent des problèmes dans leur
parcours de vie mais il vient vers les
éducateurs ou les éducateurs donc
enchaîné en faisant le travail de rue
ils peuvent rencontrer dans leurs
quartiers dans leur milieu
du coup voilà donc des contacts de liens
qui se créent à partir de là il ya des
accompagnements 10ème en place sur 2000
15 175 jeunes ont été soutenus par les
sept éducateurs de l'association
parmi eux le fils dodi va qui a
récemment lancé une pétition de soutien
on n'a pas beaucoup le temps ne les
prends parfois et ça nous a ramené des
essais c'est agréable
ne serait-ce qu de prendre un verre à la
maison café et discuter avec eux dirait
ce qui s'est passé avec les enfants s'il
y avait une difficulté et nous dit c'est
ça nous a mis en confiance
on a mis en confiance en 2015 500 mille
euros était versée par le département et
130 me par la commune de plaisir pour le
maire la fin de la convention est dictée
par le nouveau mode de fonctionnement de
la municipalité
aujourd'hui nous avons mis en place à
plaisir une convention est un contrat
plutôt globale sur l'ensemble de la vie
de solidarité avec à l'intérieur la
politique de la ville avec la réussite
éducative avec toute une série d'actions
et nous avons mis en place une dizaine
de médiateurs qui sont des médiateurs
qui aujourd'hui travail en
transversalité avec les associations les
conseils de quartier pour l'élu c'est
apporter aux habitants une nouvelle
approche pour l'association le problème
de compétence est posée une
complémentarité des médiateurs et des
éducateurs serait nécessaire